let's speak to some of these great
people members and non-members alike we
take calls on fridays via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to alex from
baltimore alex go ahead
hey david can you hear me yes i can
cool
um i got a question about um
i got a question about um publicly
funded elections sure
so
i know it's a long shot in the united
states but uh
so hypothetically if one were to happen
how does the money get doled out because
i know you know if it's a governor or a
president technically there's like eight
independents and a bunch of other random
parties no one's heard of so do they get
a share of the money or is it do they
have to meet a certain qualification
again this is a great question this is a
great question so listen there's no one
way to set this up but you could you
could establish so what do we mean by
public funding of elections the idea is
to limit the amount of money that can go
into an election
and
it and i have to say it's so loud where
you are alex would it be okay if maybe i
mute you to answer because it's this is
a very important issue
uh hang on can you hear me better right
now yeah i can hear you fine it's just
there's so much background noise so the
way we would set it up would be we might
say okay
once you meet a certain signature
threshold
then you qualify and it can't be like
300 signatures right it really has to be
significant so you don't have 100 people
then you get x amount of money you get x
amount of local television time and
whatever you could do it on a polling
basis you have to be polling at least x
percent now some people will say well
the problem is
you need money to get the polling and it
okay but so that's that's another way
that it could be looked at you also
might have different thresholds
depending on the population of the state
or
the race that you're you're running so
you wouldn't necessarily expect uh you
know a senate candidate and a
congressional candidate to have the same
thresholds in terms of signatures at
least because one is drawing from a much
larger population base so there's not
one answer to the question but it's a
really important question that has to be
crystal clear when you put these systems
in
place okay cool yeah i figured that was
the end i also didn't know is there any
examples of other places that do it
i don't have any offhand to be perfectly
frank
interesting yeah let me research that
all right let me just do one more quick
i promise sure um
what is your guilty pleasure foods the
thing that's just greasy and nasty and
no nutritional value but it's delicious
and you tear it up every time man i i
don't know greasy and nasty i avoid
foods i consider nasty you know well i i
mean like looking not tasting
i i don't i don't know i mean you know
what cheesesteak that's all spread out
you know it looks a certain way yeah no
i'm not big i mean i think you know the
the argentinian slash italian chicken
dish milanesa which is a fried chicken
cutlet i am a big fan of i guess that
would be considered greasy although i
don't have it very often i guess i could
also say what about like a dessert like
something that's overly ridiculously
sweet i'm a big uh i'm a big tiramisu
guy
that's not a bad choice yeah all right
that's all i had thanks for taking my
call alex quick question would you agree
that the top desserts are
tiramisu
flan
uh chocolate lava cake
and pistachio baklava do you agree with
that take
um you have a very mediterranean take on
desserts don't you
um i'm
i'm kind of a good old american boy when
it comes to desserts oh please don't
bring up apple pie if you bring up apple
pie we're gonna have to cut it off uh
let me meet you in the middle then how
about a key lime pie okay
that's less obvious overtly offensive
i'm more of a tart sweet guy so it's
things like apple pie lemon meringue
that kind of stuff all right well we'll
agree to disagree my friend thank you
yes very respectfully of course see
people can have differences of opinion
and still communicate
in a respectful way
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below